-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and we ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So since the NFL Playoffs
are in full swing,
I sent out the hashtag
#MyFootballSuperstition
and asked you guys to tweet out
your funny or silly
superstitions that you do
when you're watching the game.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
My Football Superstition
tweets from you guys.
Here we go. This first one's
from @kkpollardkk.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mouthing words ]
[ Applause continues ]
This one's from @DavinPants.
[ Chuckles ]
-Davin Pants?
-Davin -- Davin Pants.
-Oh.
-He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Why?
-Wow.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Pants and socks.
-Why was he wearing one sock?
-And what happened
the night before?
-Hope it's a different sock.
This one's from @OrangeTerrys.
They say...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckling ] What?
That's kind of good.
-That's a good idea.
-This one's from
@MouseHandStan51.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mouthing words ]
[ Applause continues ]
This one's from @AraRaeStew.
She says...
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Rules are rules.
-Yeah.
-Get back in the bath.
-I'm going outside.
-[ Brooklyn accent ]
Get back in the bathroom.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
This one's from @BuddyChampagne.
-Oh, yeah.
-Oh!
-Uh, he says, uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's not true.
That's not real.
-No.
It's worked every time.
-That's not true.
-Yeah, it's not a football.
-Yeah.
-Wh--
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckling ] What is it?
-I don't know.
It's not a football.
-This one's from @smedee.
She says...
They sent a pic.
Look at the dog there.
-Aww!
-Hey, bud!
[ Laughing ]
[ Applause ]
Is that a beer?
-[ Chuckles ]
"Beer me."
-This last one's from
@AnthonyDiPiero7.
He says...
Oh, there you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.